i'm emily compagno i'm guy benson i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
friday february 18th 2022 i'm lisa brady
if they want to win in november midterm
candidates may have to win over cobit
moms instead of soccer moms i do think
that there's an awareness on the
democrat side that they have sort of
lost the ball lost control of some of
these issues whether or not they can get
their arms around them in time for their
midterms in november
is anybody's guess at this point we're
watching we speak with fox's martha
mccallum
i'm chris foster the nascar cup series
starts sunday with the daytona 500.
everybody comes here with the thought
that they can win the race everybody
comes here with zero points everybody
comes here thinking that they can win
the biggest race of the year and they
can't it's feasible especially with this
new car
and i'm jimmy fella i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the general election isn't until
november but the build-up to the
midterms is well underway with crowded
primaries taking shape in multiple
states as republicans try to take back
control of congress the american people
are going to have an opportunity this
fall
to give a midterm report card
on the performance
of this all democratic government senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell
outlining a republican agenda this week
but what democrats said thursday in new
york at a state nominating convention
may be a good indication of how they'll
try to keep control at a time when our
nation is deeply
and dangerously divided hillary clinton
was the keynote speaker it is one thing
to have political disagreements
those are natural and healthy
but it is an entirely different thing
all together
to lose a shared sense
of truth
facts and reality itself this as
president biden continues his
infrastructure tour highlighting
projects funded by the bill he signed
last november we're reinvesting in our
economy in our and in our people
reclaiming our leadership and creating
millions of jobs for building a better
america visiting ohio thursday for the
fourth time as president well i think
you know a it's interesting that they've
decided to spend time and travel energy
and all of that in ohio martha mccallum
is the fox news politics co-anchor and
anchor and executive editor of the story
on fox news channel obviously when you
look ahead in the big political picture
there's a very significant ohio senate
race coming up and i think there is an
effort to point to the things that are
positive and that have been passed and
really you know infrastructure is pretty
much the only big
thing post-covet relief which is also
was also significant that they can point
to one of the things that i find
interesting though is that this is a 1.9
trillion dollar
deal
of u.s taxpayer money and we really
haven't seen i'm kind of surprised that
the approach on their part isn't to sort
of roll out you know these are the top
five projects which have already begun
with your with your tax dollars and we
expect that this airport or this highway
will be done in 2025 or you know i think
it would be great if they gave some sort
of tangible impact on people's lives and
explaining what are their priority
projects and what's the time frame for
them because too often we just see
money that gets spent in washington and
gets voted on and they don't really hear
much about it you know they don't really
see where that money went so i think
that would be a really positive way for
them to
communicate
on that story and of course as he was
leaving he discussed briefly on his way
to ohio that we are in a very tenuous
situation with this russia ukraine
border crisis and
that he believes that something could
happen within days so he's got a lot on
his plate
you know the white house and democrats
like senate majority leader chuck
schumer up for re-election this year
insist there's a record of
accomplishment to run on and that their
plans
will make things better if they're just
allowed to keep going
is that easier to sell by november
well obviously they had
you know they had a lot of hiccups with
bbb and i think there's a lot of
reflection probably on all of their
parts about whether or not
they should have gone at it in a
different way because they have such a
tight margin in the senate uh they went
for sort of the whole
enchilada so to speak of of passing bbb
and ended up not getting across the
finish line because they didn't have uh
senators mansion and cinema so um and
breaking up those deals into smaller
pieces um you know
price controls on on drugs all that kind
of stuff seems to be the way they're
going now although then they're faced
with the difficult prospect that they
can't really do that with reconciliation
they've got to get two-thirds of the
senate so they're really in a in a tough
spot because they have such slim margins
and i think one of the biggest things
that
they have to be thinking about now and i
just wonder how
deeply they're thinking about making
changes on this is just that he was
elected as a moderate president someone
who would bring calm you know sort of
end the chaos that
surrounded many parts of the prior
administration but what they did was
they came in and reversed everything
that was done by the prior
administration including keystone and a
number of other things that were working
in terms of you know the goals that were
set for them and energy independence and
all of that
and tax cuts and tax reform those things
that were all seen as
seen as positives on the republican side
for the trump administration um and
reversed them so you know they find
themselves in a really difficult
situation in terms of passing anything
because they have gone so far to the
progressive side of their constituency
and they sort of cut off at the knees
the ability to work with republicans so
it's a bind to be sure and you know
that's why we find it fascinating to
cover every day to see you know how they
might pivot and how they might be able
to turn that around
well republicans in the meantime appear
to be capitalizing on the millions of
parents who are angry about
school mask mandates especially um
you know is that still going to be an
issue in the fall and could there be a
lot of crossover voters on issues like
masking in schools
well i think that's certainly a huge
story to watch you know we remember the
reagan democrats who remember the
security moms the soccer moms and in
every election there's always this group
of independent voters who may you know
align themselves more with the
republican side of the democrat side but
they move based on what's going on in
the country and it's interesting these
dcc
polling data that leaked the other day
said that democrats that they had polled
said that they found their own party to
be preachy and judgmental and that the
republican side was capitalizing very
effectively on culture issues like crt
and defund police and covet issues
masking in schools all of that
so the republicans seem to be they seem
to have better game where those things
are concerned right now and i think
there is a wake-up call underway on the
democrat side that uh a lot of that
they've missed the mark on a lot of
these things but i do think that there's
an awareness on the democrat side that
they have sort of lost control of some
of these issues whether or not they can
get their arms around them in time for
their midterms in november is anybody's
guess at this point we're watching
and that's on top of the other issues
that republicans have been highlighting
like high inflation
which the polls show is on a lot of
people's minds one of the narratives
from many democrats though is voting
rights and linking that to the capitol
riot and trying to make the case that
democracy remains under attack on some
level could that argument
make support
for president trump or from president
trump in any of these midterm races a
liability for republican candidates
well it remains to be seen but what
we're seeing is that voting rights
issues
are not really what's top of mind with
voters it's not resonating the way that
all of that sort of alarmist language
might suggest so
at this point i would say no you know i
think people are pretty reasonable when
they look at what's going on when they
think about something like bringing your
id to vote they don't really see that as
jim crow 2.0 especially when you live in
a world where you have to show your vax
card to get in the door of a restaurant
you know i think people sort of say look
an appropriate form of id is not
egregious it is not undercutting
anyone's right to vote so i think the
argument you know as passionate as it is
and as you know deeply held and i i'm
sure sincerely held on the part of many
people it doesn't seem to be pulling a
lot of weight with a majority of the
american public at this point
what democrats are facing with president
biden in terms of his poll numbers
potentially weighing them down
how does that compare to what
republicans
face with trump who has had a pretty
good track record of endorsing
candidates over the years for instance
but of course has had some pull trouble
of his own historically you know i'm
just wondering is the division in the
democrat party easier to overcome
than in the republican party if it's
less about personality and more about
plans and priorities
i mean that's a great question and it
cuts both ways you know
generally speaking historically speaking
when you have a president who is in that
40 percent range you're gonna have a
tough time getting your party to
maintain their majorities in the midterm
elections so that is clearly an issue
for biden i think there are a couple of
factors that could improve his numbers
between now and november
if covic continues to decline i saw a
poll recently
that coveted ranked around 10
in terms of people's concerns
27 saw inflation as the most urgent
issue
so
if covid continues to wane and we all
certainly hope it does
that turns into something that does not
weigh on the biden presidency right now
if you see any improvement in inflation
you know that's something that they'll
be able to point to to maybe improve
some of those numbers if the russia
ukraine situation resolves itself in a
way that the bite administration can
take a bit of credit for that's also
a potential plus in pulling their
numbers back on the trump side i mean
it's been in the 30 range over the
course of trump's presidency and beyond
in terms of people who tend to align
with him so these candidates are going
to have to find a way to
get that 30 percent of voters to turn
out for them and we see it happening
already in places like pennsylvania
where you've got an interesting gop
primary going on between dave mccormick
and dr oz where they're both trying to
curate the favor of those trump voters
and also to present sort of something
new and something that's individual in
their own candidacy
we're less than nine months to the
general election part of the midterms
now uh the first round of the fox news
power rankings are out estimating kind
of which races are competitive or not at
this point still early in general
um but georgia is is one that's listed
as a toss-up that senate race and the
governor's race there could also be
reflective of many of the national
political debates going on right now
um absolutely i mean you know i think
that uh there are going to be divisions
that are brought up in some of these
places where
you know sort of big picture republicans
might say we really don't need to fight
this battle you know we should be sort
of supporting one candidate but um but
that's not not what's happening and you
look at the toss-up races you've got
arizona georgia nevada new hampshire and
that open pennsylvania race that i just
mentioned where
people are going to have to you know
find a way to walk that line between
trump and mcconnell or trump and the
future
and present to present a positive uh
picture for the future and of course all
of that makes it a really fascinating
eight nine months to come
just one other quick question for you
about money because
both parties are raising tremendous
amounts of it um and even in an age
where you know it's easier than ever to
get information out there if you're a
candidate thanks to the internet and
social media um the money really still
seems to matter
you know
it i guess it does and it doesn't i
think that
one of the great last sentences going
back to the election in 2016 and
president trump won new hampshire um you
know on a pretty small budget
and
jeb bush had spent millions in new
hampshire and came up really short
barely registered
so i think that a dynamic candidate
does not necessarily in this environment
as you point out with social media and
all the other ways to reach voters
require it but what happens is the money
becomes sort of a measure of intensity a
measure of interest on both sides so um
you know money in politics is a
interesting issue it does as i say
measure intensity and interest but i'm
not sure that it necessarily measures
out huh
certainly a busy year ahead if nothing
else fox's martha mccallum
also hosted the untold story podcast
thank you very very much for your time
thank you so much it's great to be with
you lisa
[Music]
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
notice the great american race and the
super bowl of stock car racing the
daytona 500 was first run in 1959 since
1982 the race has been opening day for
the nascar cup series two of the drivers
racing in florida sunday cory lejoy and
landon castle are driving for spire
motorsports one of the smaller newer
teams in the cup series the race airs on
the fox broadcast network and there's a
four-part documentary about spire
streaming now on fox nation called road
to daytona with part three out today and
part four debuting next thursday a few
days after the race i want to be known
as daytona 500 winning spire motorsports
team
you can't be reckoned you can't make
mistakes some of these drivers they put
the helmet on they forget about
everything they just go and that's it
they don't care if they rank
we have to be smart about not wrecking
and finishing races and i just i
wouldn't be here if it weren't for
daytona international speedway it's the
biggest race in the world for a reason
and fox nation is sponsoring linden
castle's number 77 car at daytona that
car is one of nascar's new next-gen cars
drivers are using this season i mean i
think there's a lot of different pieces
of that puzzle
i think a huge part of it is obviously
the fact that now from from first to
40th in the cup field you have the same
product it's the same chassis kevin
bellacourt's the team's crew chief
everybody has their own manufacturer
there's gonna be chevy manufacturer body
panels and toyota and ford and that's
going to look different which is great
it should um but from for from a
competition standpoint for all of us
crew chiefs we all have the same piece
to work with now um whereas before it
was just a it was a spending game right
it was just who could who had the most
people who had the most support from
their manufacturer who could spend the
most money in the wind tunnel who could
find the most downforce now obviously
the best drivers
still drive for the best teams most the
time and you're gonna still see kyle
larson and chase elliott all those guys
running good that's not going to stop
them from being good but i think what it
does is it changes the gap
from from first to 40 so now you're
going to get to see people like corey
lejoy
that where they've been maybe hindered
by their equipment up to this point in
their career be able to go show their
talent showcase their ability a little
bit better
it's an opportunity to be working in the
same box as those guys and so whoever
can find speed the quickest whoever can
find ways to make the car go fast make
their driver happy is gonna is gonna
excel um obviously the big teams are
still gonna be tough they're gonna be
good we're chasing them they have really
smart obviously really really smart
people really really good drivers but
what nascar has done with this car is it
gives
all of us kind of an equal starting
point so to speak for right now in 2022
and it's also a good thing for the
owners
they can actually look and know what
it's it's it was kind of a limitless
expenditure before where you would
always have something calming and
another expenditure coming in there's
some of those things popping up with an
action car that that maybe we didn't
know but
ideally the way nascar's got it planned
out is is the owners can have a good
idea of what what everything's going to
cost every year and what it's going to
look like easier for everybody to budget
even easier for everybody to make plans
as far as that goes to on the business
side yeah i mean before like like you
said part of this but part of the team
was the engineering and designing and
manufacturing and that cost millions and
millions and millions of dollars
um and now it just leaves it puts the
sport more on the track right i mean
this is your car you race it it becomes
more about the skill
of the driver and the pit crew and not
what led up to it in the you know the
weeks and months before that
absolutely yeah that's exactly right
it's it gives us all the same so to
speak sandbox to be playing in and and
now it's up to us to go
go make the most speed out of it and and
put the best effort on the racetrack and
like i said that's not going to be easy
they're still they're still the big team
they're going to be successful they've
got really smart people they've got
great people over there that are going
to think of stuff and make these cars go
fast um but yeah it's it's definitely
going to make it i think great for the
fans to watch it's going to be exciting
the other great thing about the next gen
car is it looks so much like the street
cars um i love that i think it looks
really cool on the racetrack it gives
people at home that are watching nascar
races a little bit more um you know
similarity if they've got a one of one
of these manufacturer cars sitting in
their driveway it looks a lot more
similar so i think that's good too
because i feel like we've gotten away
from that a little bit in the last few
years in the cup stairs yeah i mean it
makes a little you're like it makes it a
little more fun for viewers if you're
watching indycar it's a good you know
it's it's it's a completely different
species than what you're what you've got
in your driveway but if you've got a
chevy camaro
you can kind of put yourself mentally
uh behind the wheel
at daytona i mean look racing's one of
those things where maybe especially
non-fans might say well i can't dunk a
basketball but i know how to drive
what makes
cup drivers great you have to be seven
feet tall you don't have to be super
muscular
um i imagine there's more training
mentally and physically than there was
years ago right
absolutely it's there's there's a few
things obviously i mean there's there's
a in my opinion just a very some guys
just have a god given natural ability to
do it um and and and they're just really
really good at driving vehicles and and
i mean i'm going to use kyle larson's
example anything that he gets in he goes
fast that is not by coincidence he's
just extraordinarily talented
any one of these guys that races on
sunday is very very very good there's
nobody that's not a good race car driver
in the cup series um so
and and attributes that make them make
them good is just it's just a skill set
they have an ability to to feel what the
car is doing and feel what it needs to
do to go fast and be able to control it
at a high speed obviously put themselves
in dangerous situations and
things that a lot of people just aren't
willing to do
and that's one attribute that makes them
really good like you said from the
physical standpoint all these guys have
really stepped up on their
um training and a lot of them eat
healthy and they're working out every
day i mean it's it's a very physical
thing to be in a race car for three and
a half four hours on a sunday afternoon
and i mean even here at daytona where
it's not going to be super hot it'll be
a lot but when we get to june july
august the summer months these guys will
sweat out 8 9 10 11 pounds during a race
so it's very physical it's 130 140
degrees in the cockpit so imagine
sitting in a sauna with a fire suit and
a helmet on for which is three layers
thick so basically a big blanket wrapped
around you for four hours and basically
just getting water to drink during the
day and not
not having anything to eat or anything
it's very physically and mentally
demanding so i think all those between
the talent and then the mental and
physical toughness to be able to handle
what they have to do on a sunday
afternoon raise four or 500 miles is
what makes them good
nascar drivers aren't you know just
suddenly nascar drivers what what's the
entry into it like i mean do you have to
is it
necessarily now a rich kid sport i mean
is there a is there is there an
equivalent of a little league or a pop
one or football where kids can be
ushered into it
i hate to use the term rich kid sport
but i mean it's it's just it's a fact of
money money is is necessary to make
things go so and there's only so many
owners that can
that can back so many kids you know
coming up through the ranks but yes
there is there is lower levels um you
can go down i mean we can go all the way
down to just starting when they're young
i mean you got five six seven eight year
old kids and go-karts at small race
tracks all over the country learning and
but once you get into the into the
bigger divisions the arca series is kind
of really the first series where you get
started and you'll see 16 17 year old
kids in in that series and those are
full-bodied stock cars and then they'll
work from there as they progress into
the truck series which i think a lot a
lot more people are common probably with
the truck series that's kind of our
third level series and that's a great
series it's about 200 250 mile races
usually about a two-hour race all pickup
trucks really really cool great racing
and a great place for kids to learn they
run on a lot of the tracks at the cup
series runs mile and a half daytona
talladega so that's where they can
really get their feet wet at the speed
and the size of the track and racing
that's going to be like on saturdays and
sundays and then the next level below
cup is what we call the xfinity series
which is also a series very similar to
cup um it's full-bodied cars that
run the same manufacturers as the cup
series it's just shorter races a little
bit different horsepower a little bit
different body package but a good place
for kids to make the step from the truck
series up that would be what we would
equate to minor league baseball once
they're in the xfinity series generally
they're linked up with a bigger team at
this point and they're learning to try
to get themselves adapted and ready for
sunday when a seat opens up because
there's only 40 spots on there obviously
right um
are most guys involved in the sport at
your level did you i assume you drove
growing up you grew up in daytona the
500's big part of your childhood
did your mom your mom snuck you in a few
times right
yes i i told that story off the cuff and
mom's actually driving down here right
now she comes down for the 500 she lives
in north carolina now um but she comes
down for the 500 every year so yeah my
mom my mom did sneak me to the racetrack
when we were young um she uh
she was it's just one of the things it's
just a funny story and i remember she
had a chevy cavalier and then and the
ticket price to get in the tunnel was
like three times what it was to pay for
the ticket just to get into the pit area
when you got inside so she'd put me in
the back of the cavalier and as soon as
we get to the tunnel i pulled a little
latch out of the trunk and dropped the
back seat and come in and uh my mom's
like the most honest nice person in the
world too so i like i feel like i'm
painting this horrible picture but but
it's kind of a funny story and we laugh
about it she was mad at me when she
found out i told people about it but um
but yeah the daytona 500 is huge to me
um just i grew up literally if you drive
out the tunnel and turn four and drive
straight down that road five miles you'd
run right into my neighborhood and i was
here anytime there was a racecar on
racetrack i was here um via the rolex 24
or any of the nascar events or anything
so came over here a lot with my dad too
um growing up and my mom was big big
loved coming over here and i got to
spend a lot of time in the infield
watching these races and it's just all i
ever wanted to do so every time i come
back to daytona it's special um i've had
some special moments here too i've run
good in the truck series as a crew chief
and and had a couple good runs in the
xfinity series but but to come back here
for the daytona 500 this is my second
one and it's just it's so special it's
our super bowl so for that to be in my
hometown and just having all the
memories every time i pull back in here
it's it's really special
well it's funny that you call it the
super bowl daytona's the daytona 500 is
a little weird in that it's the marquee
event but it's the start of the season
you know most sports have their marquee
event
at the end i mean maybe not horse racing
if you consider the kentucky derby their
marquee event um but it is a little bit
odd that uh well i guess it's also a
great celebration of the sport like hey
we're kicking off with the biggest race
of the year the best way i explain to
people it is it's different like
everything else the the build-up is to
the end of the year right the champion
and all that stuff which we have that
too in phoenix so the cool thing about
the daytona 500 is like you said it's
our marquee event but basically the
other 37 races of the year we basically
spend three or four or five days
preparing for those races for the
daytona 500 we spend three months
preparing for the daytona 500. like
we've been working on we go to
california the week after the 500 in las
vegas and and phoenix and those are our
next three races so obviously we're
working on that stuff we got to be ahead
of the game and and ready to go to those
racetracks but since basically for sure
after christmas when we came back in
january 85 to 90 of the focus of every
one of these race teams is on this race
everybody comes here with the thought
that they can win the race everybody
comes here with zero points everybody
comes here thinking that they can win
the biggest race of the year and they
can't it's feasible especially with this
new car so i think that's what makes it
special and not everybody necessarily
sees from the outside is that our season
is very long it runs from february to
november there's a lot of races and it's
it's they're all exciting they're great
races and we have a huge build up to the
playoffs at the end of the year and
there's eliminations during the playoffs
and we have a great season finale at
phoenix i thought that was an awesome
event last year was great to have all
the fans back there and that's a great
market to have it but for this the the
special another thing that makes daytona
so special is that we spend so much time
preparing just for one race and you'll
watch it on sunday as as a guy rexella
falls out or a guy's has something
happen or somebody finishes the second
loses the lead on the last lap like it's
heartbreaking it's it's just looks like
the guys that lost the super bowl last
sunday right it's we've prepared two
months for this one race and put all our
eggs in this basket trying to come win
and uh and so that's i think another
thing that makes it really special
uh kevin bellacourt crew chief of the 77
fox nation sponsored car this year
lyndon castle on behind the wheel corey
le joy the other member of the team i'm
running for spyro this uh on sunday good
luck have a good uh have a good time too
i appreciate it guys thanks for having
me on enjoy the race it'll be fun the
car looks awesome so we're looking
forward to getting rolling sunday
getting schooled is a podcast hosted by
fox nation's abby hornacek each week
abby and her expert guests tackle topics
we take for granted and help explain the
roots and meanings behind them subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
is listening to fox news
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
462 days that's how long it took a small
boat launched in october of 2020 in new
hampshire to be found thousands of miles
away the boat was just six feet long
called the rye rip tides and decorated
with artwork by students from rye junior
high school in rye new hampshire it was
equipped with a tracking device and it
had quite the journey before it was
found on february 1st by a 6th grader in
norway more than 8 300 miles from rye
the boat had lost its hull and keel and
was covered in barnacles but the deck
and the cargo were still intact
so what kind of cargo did the kids find
when they opened it photos fall leaves
acorns and state quarters to name a few
things
the rye students started working with a
main nonprofit on the project back in
2018 before setting it out on the
atlantic ocean excited about following
its path
the gps went silent for parts of the
journey but the kids kept watch
it came back online during hurricane
season in august and september before
going dark again
and on january 30th they learned that
the boat had appeared to hit land just
west of a small island in norway the
students in norway are planning a call
with the rye junior high students soon
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind so the u.s customs
and border protection had over 153 000
migrant encounters at our southern
border in january which is nearly double
the year before which oh by the way was
the highest number on record since 1960.
now this doesn't concern me as much as
it should because the way biden's
governing pretty soon everybody's going
to be running into mexico if inflation
keeps skyrocketing and crime keeps going
up it's only a matter of time before
mexico's presidential candidates are
chanting build a wall but all jokes
aside this is a terrible situation for
our country because the border's the
front door to our house and biden's left
it wide open normally you like to know
who's coming and going from your house
and you certainly want to lock the door
at night to make sure no bad guys swing
by but we're not doing any of that and
it's costing us big time folks the
fentanyl flooding our southern border
has led to a record level of overdose
deaths last year and as the illegal
border crossings go up the overdose
rate's gonna climb right with it who
knows maybe biden wants drugs coming in
because absent being high i can't think
of any other reason people would vote
for him be sure to listen to fox across
america with me jimmy fella weekdays
from noon to three on the fox news app
and foxnewsradio.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcast network
download listen and be inspired with
lauren green's lighthouse faith fox news
religion correspondent lauren green uses
her wealth of stories to take the
listener on a unique journey of
spiritual discovery subscribe and listen
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes